let's go alive
instead of life
all right so i wonder what first
question you have cooked
for us should give people a little bit
of coffee
give people a little bit of context i
met vg here
vincent in the no limits society
nls which has been to new mesaro and
their team's
ascensionary enlightenment awakening
group and vg and i have been
hitting some really good tennis balls
raw unfiltered
reflecting purifying to one another and
it's been
really fun and so his calling is
people experiencing joy is a higher form
of love
which i'm really excited to talk about
on the episode as well but let's start
things off
with vg on the classic question of
talk to us about how you transformed
yourself
out of person consciousness into the
awareness and into creator
okay i never transformed anything
actually i've always been
exactly the same thing but i did
work together
with this incarnation vincent
and yeah i helped him
give birth to a higher version of
himself and you know many people like to
use
the analogy of a caterpillar becoming a
butterfly but
that's not my experience at all
um it's i experience it more
as a snake a snake that when it
grows needs to shed its previous
skin uh to to get into a new one and
it's not something that happens just
once and then you fly
it's really something that needs to
happen each time
that your consciousness grows you know
because
as a incarnated human being
you know many people many religious
people
have this especially christians
have this idea that you have to humble
yourself
you have to become very very small you
have to make yourself small
because god is so great
anything any attempt to be bigger
it's an offense to god and things like
that you know these misconceptions
while it's even it's contradicting the
very logic
of it the very logic of it is if
god is that big and you and he says
he is in you and you want to to
receive god you have to make yourself as
big as you can you know you
you will never be big enough to host god
it's impossible
so the logic is don't
humble yourself especially if your true
desire is to grow it's counterproductive
it's really an internal struggle
if you want to humble yourself while
trying to grow
so that's the the the realization
and the image which i find more
art which by the way i just came up with
because
uh it's suitable to this discussion
it's not been used by vincent nor by
vienna so far
so this snake growing is it's a
very apt image of course some people
will
probably misinterpret it but
it's okay that's how it works
i'm not sure i answered your question by
the way
hello
again please there's this style of
just i don't even know it's
how to explain it it's so uniquely you
it's so cool you just have this style of
presence and being that's just so
unapologetic and i love it it's just you
and it's the radiance of that flower
aroma
unapologetically as it is and so
yeah so what it would unpack this more
for us because
you are
you underwent this process of expansion
i apologize for being
unapologetic i'm sorry i seem to
not get the right rhythm i apologize for
being an apologetic because it may
offend some people
but you also know to not apologize for
being apologetic because that's
ridiculous because you're just
effortlessly you so it's beautiful
all right so let's get back to this so
again this expansion
for you and you co you reference to it
in a sense as
snake so unpack that more for us
um yeah you see that's always
the difficulty with using illustration
in anything i always love to
illustrate what i say with an image
and of course there is always
this tendency to to dive into the image
instead of just accepting
the imperfection of the illustration an
illustration can never be the real thing
especially when in the context of
a spiritual inquiry
so you should not see too much into the
the image
or too much in detail the image should
be kept as it is
but by the way there are also
sometimes often surprising
second or third and sometimes fourth
layer
of truth in an image especially when the
image came spontaneously out of nowhere
like it
just did because that snake
shedding its uh skin
uh analogy while
i formulated it uh
quite surprised vincent and and he was
shocked at how
accurate and apt it was and that's why
uh he went along with i to elaborate on
it and by the way
when it comes spontaneously like this
you often
find a second third fourth meaning in it
and indeed
the image of the snake is very powerful
many people have a very negative
associations
and and emotional attachments
or repulsion in this case
but the snake is a very symbolically
important animal in many context
so it probably has much more meaning
than vincent has realized now and it
will require a bit of investigation
inquiry but the first one
that i can transmit to him
and share is the
the sound of the snake
you see when you
visualize a snake
your a locution will modify itself
and you will find yourself
kissing more
the easing sound in whatever you say
and that focus
on the hissing
will um detach
your sense of identity
and will yeah will introduce a bit of
space
in between you and who you think you are
and will allow you to be
more true in fact and to to be less
uh polluted by your
a huge baggage of history
so that's one the other one is the
negative
connotation of snakes in most people's
body mind complex uh
especially in the religious
background especially if they are
christian but in most religion there are
there is
either a very negative or very positive
association or stories or myths around
the snake
so there is probably much more to be
found in that
and i think that's a drop of yum
i made task to write something about
this
all right so there's a couple components
there it sounds like the main
component in your direct experience was
going from something that had lots of
form and lots of identity lots of
distortion lots of
layers and then stripping that down like
snake skin
down to the pure bear i am awareness
was that approximately what you were
describing
well very much and you see that's why i
i'm sure
anybody watching from outside will
realize
the value you bring
when i say you i mean atlas
because of course
i am you too so
you see i i enjoy
uh the dialectic that
i am creates between
i am you and i am i in this i
am universe
and your rigor
your
devotion to truth
is a perfect balancing energy to
the total abandonment
that i express through
vincent and jian and all the other skin
layers
above them
okay perfect yeah and we have our
you see at last you see at last
how when i convey your rigor
and devotion to truth through vincent
how his affinity for joy
start manifesting in you
so it's a perfect balance
when vincent gets more precise
and rigorous
and devoted to truth at last
becomes more joyful
and less burdened by his
crushing responsibility of
constantly refining the truth focusing
on
on removing any speck
of impurity in the truth that
he is midwifing into the internet
removing all specks of impurity
midwifing truth into the internet
see this is this is another reason
go ahead no no no
you're good okay um
you go ahead you are about to expose one
speck of impurity
no not at all actually it's so beautiful
because
we'll talk about this probably in a
little bit also on the episode but
you know vg's got this ability like he
just showed you guys there
where he gives this really unique
reflection right this is what i meant
earlier by this very unapologetic direct
aroma
and he just gives you a reflection
that is really strongly saturated with
his own
understanding and it's very beautiful
and so
that was an example of it and we'll
reference to another one that he gave
during um a call that we had
later but let's unpack another
sort of understanding here most people
experience
awakening or enlightenment as both
this shedding like vincent was
describing of the onion layers
down the snake skin down to the pure
formless i am awareness and yet at the
same time they're
experiencing this expansion this very
cosmic
consciousness into that great i am into
becoming the creator at the same time
and so that's why people like nassar got
to maharash has the very famous
way of saying it is that love says i am
everything wisdom says i am nothing my
life flows between the two
right so we are beyond everything beyond
nothing just
absolute ineffable free perfection
and so i really appreciated that sort of
in fact um
that the theme of all those analogies
is transformation
and if you really want to transform
yourself you can't
really do it in a linear fashion you
can't
do it bit by bit you know
the only way you can split it into more
manageable
tasks uh in the rational
conception of of conducting a project
you know by
cutting it into smaller tasks the only
my rational way that works is to
understand that
if you want to transform your body mind
soul
higher self i am complex
of course alarm can't be changed and it
doesn't need to
uh but all the other layers can be
transformed and
you can you can approach each layer
in a different fashion because you see
those image of peeling the onion
or shedding skin are valuable to a
certain extent
uh even the caterpillar into a butterfly
but
the only way it works is to consider
more or less separately the body
the mind the soul
and the higher self i
don't believe
i don't see how
we can how our incarnation
can be of any use to refine and
transform
anything from the higher self and above
but uh definitely our body
we all know by now that we can refine
our body that we can even transform it
and that is pretty much the
analogy of the caterpillar becoming a
butterfly
you can be a fat crawling
slow caterpillar
and transform into a very light
very harmonious graceful dancer
of life by working a bit on your body
it can help it does uh
you can work on your mind in fact that's
probably for most of us
uh the the biggest chunk of the work
and that the peeling of the onion is the
apt
image because the objective is
nothingness
in the mind the ability of nothingness
because
obviously as anyone watching can see
there is no way to express
these things without some usage of
language of memory
of even some pre-wired algorithms
in one's mind
it's also what we call culture and
society and language and
if we want to communicate if we want to
exchange we can do it
silently in other dimensions but there
is a beauty in bringing it
into these dimensions this dense
uh heavy but
very in fact it's a slowing down we can
see this incarnation as a slowing down
of our super fast
uh higher layers
so the higher we go the faster it goes
and
when you are a toddler and you want to
learn to walk
you can't just run right away you have
to
everything has to be slowed down to
enable you to learn the movement
so this incarnation yes it's a gift
it's a painful gear because everything
is so slow and heavy
but it's what it takes if if we are to
learn
the moves of a supersonic
flying a multi-dimensional being
and be able to to handle it
at as a supersonic i
probably mean super lightning
speed we have us to train into a more
uh slowed down environment so each image
is apt
and each layer is up and it's not
entirely true that they are separated
that much but yes we feel that there is
a separation between the dimension
and we can work on the body we can work
on the mind
we can even work on the soul i mean the
soul
s o u which is
the remaining identification that we
still carry from one life to the other
that we can still work on it while
incarnated
and then of course the the
higher self above that soul is probably
what
in my intuition we can't work on uh
consciously we probably
are already working on it and
not not even unconscious beyond
unconscious
at those realms we don't have access to
it's probably happening
especially outside of time because
time is one of those artificial
slowing down of our self that
has been gifted to us to be able to work
on slow motion on
our movements as if as a dancer
we wanted to do a very beautiful irish
dance
but somehow we have to rehearse
in slow motion
well maybe i was a bit long on this but
uh
i love that so there's a couple
components
i love the transformation component i
love that metamorphosis component the
caterpillar to the butterfly
the incarnation being a painful gift
when you really
stretch your essence out to truly taste
and touch
eternity infinity when you do that and
you
recognize that this is an appearance of
that absolute
that is so communing
with your true nature just that
recognition in itself
and i also really appreciated how with
the onion layers getting down to nothing
that's the same recognition again
by all of these mystics and these sages
is that
all motion is illusory as parmenidus
said 2500 years ago and meanwhile
heraclitus said everything flows ponte
rey
and so the ultimate seems to very much
be a synthesis between those two you
will never
stop becoming as these firework
expressions individuated fractals that
turn back inward and find their true
nature
yet at the same time you never move
there is absolute void absolute
stillness absolute shunya
and so that's this fascinating
dynamicism
that is still
yeah and um you see also what happens
is that many people take the wrong tool
to do the wrong
the right job but they take the wrong
tool and
not only it's not helpful and it doesn't
work
but it even damages
what you are trying to accomplish for
example as i mentioned in the refining
of the body
the apt image is butterfly or there are
probably much
better images uh
maybe the bird coming out of his egg or
whatever
um but i wanna also comment on how you
called it mastery in in the process of
dancing
also that i really enjoyed as well
yeah because i'm a dancer i love dance
there is
you know um it's very difficult it's
extremely difficult i don't think it's
accessible to
all of us to express
to talk to talk about
the truth with language
without distorting it to the point you
know beyond recognition
uh it's only a very small percentage of
the population which has
been forced through enough
rigorous uh grammar
and vocabulary training
at use from you and throughout life
to be able to uh express
true language the circumference of the
truth
without distorting it beyond recognition
but in terms of non-verbal communication
we all have the ability
to express you can never express
exactly the truth it's just not possible
but you can
dance around the black hole you know at
the
at the horizon you can dance
you can dance around the horizon
of the singularity point
and it can be authentic it can be
intense it can be
true in the human sense
you can do any uh most of us are able to
express
non-verbally something very close to the
truth
but only a few
have gone to enough painstaking
trial and error in language to be able
to use language and not
totally pollute and reap
the fragile yet eternal
periphery of the truth because we'll
never reach the truth
with language or with the expression i
don't know
exactly how it happens beyond the higher
self we'll see that
so but what i wanted to say is use the
right tool
the peeling of the onion is perfect uh
well it's not perfect
it's a very good it's an art image
of the process of refining your mind
refining your mind by the way it's not
possible
the real you have to break it
you know to peel an onion you have to
break you have to break it you can do it
gently but
in the end you are breaking the onion
because what
has to remain is nothing or not nothing
the ability of nothing which means
you have to reach the you have to peel
and
break this onion until you are able
to switch it off and switch it on
when you want to use language or when
you want to
to protect your body against any
aggression
or if you want to build a house or
anything like that
anything material or negative
or protective it's a very useful tool
or to access language it's very useful
tool
but it's not it's something that you
have to gain the ability of switching
off
that's why the image of peeling the
onion
it's a very good representation of the
right way
the right tool to
purify your mind which
once again it's not about purifying it
it's about
finding the on and off switch that's all
for the body and you see and many people
use
that tool of peeling it down to nothing
on the body you know those people who
are maniacs
of fasting but no
don't fast slow down
there is the fasting of your body
it's occasionally helpful if you have
accumulated
too many toxins or if it's too heavy
or if it doesn't uh satisfy
your heart fine
trim it down or or turn it or a tune it
or
do whatever you want but by the way the
objective is not to peel it down to
nothing
so stop using the analogy of the peeling
of the onion
when it comes to the body okay this
extreme aesthetism
is counterproductive because it
reinforces the mind
while you diminish the body and the body
is not a hindrance
in incarnation the whole idea of
incarnating is to get a body and use it
so so i think many of us
uh have been misguided into
thinking that we have to reduce the body
to nothing
while it's not my experience at all
it's not vincent's experience in fact
vincent is pretty
overweight as you can see and
there it's not a hindrance for dance it
is
for the duration of the dance but it's
not a
hindrance for the
grace of the dance so so write
you the right tool in the case of the
body
if you want to tone the body there are
many ways and
i'm not an expert in that there are many
experts
but be aware of anyone
advising you to get rid of the body or
or beat it down
of us you know
kind of destroying it in a way
while for the mind yes for the mind you
need to destroy it
you need not to destroy it you need to
yeah to be able to switch it off and on
so so the process in life is first we
build a very strong ego and then we
have to be able to deconstruct it
so it's it's true it's it's really like
a peeling an onion
if you want to peel the onion right you
don't just cut
the onion you don't tear
the leaves you you gently but firmly
peel them off and you keep all of them
and by the way you use them and eat them
after
but of the onion nothing is left
and then finally on the soul the way to
work on the soul
that's the snake analogy the soul
is your it's your it's your concept
of the vat of the vastness
of consciousness
your channel is pretty advanced i've
gone through it yesterday so i believe
your follow your followers or your it's
not followers they are not following i
guess
at that level they are really your
your
okay it's too vast that is your family
yeah okay yeah soul family so
they are advanced enough to know that
consciousness that's what
i am is that's what god is that's
infinite everything it's
all that is i believe most of us have
kind of got the notion that's how it is
but it's not our belief we still
have a conception of consciousness which
is limited
and that's our soul and so
in that's why the in the development of
our soul
the right the apt
uh image the shading of the skin of the
sk snake
the just just grow just don't be humble
in your soul don't be humble in your
consciousness
just grow it grow it grow it grow it and
if you have to shed
the skin but don't adapt your growth
to the skin of your beliefs
if your beliefs are hindering the growth
of your consciousness
shed those beliefs of course you will
fall into you will not fall you will
grow into higher beliefs
but there will still be beliefs there
will still be limiting but
at least you are expanding your
consciousness
and my understanding
is that when you grow
to certain vastness your consciousness
um then even the maintaining
of a body of an incarnate body becomes a
hindrance and then
that's probably when we move on to
higher rearms to to continue the same
uh the similar work anyway
so at last
i love i love the part where you
referenced how
language you have to be very trained
and precise like precision consciousness
to be able to use
language to tiptoe dance play
with this ineffable but yet non-verbally
speaking you can more easily dance
around the black hole singularity i
thought that was also
a great way of talking about it and
you're right that
a lot of awakening and enlightenment is
fundamentally just recognizing
the paramountness of consciousness
itself
of awareness itself that you can't have
a reality without an observer or a
witness
and then you are that which creates the
observer
and the reality to endlessly explore
and you'll never come to the end you're
the source of infinite possibilities
welcome to your true nature
yay and you see at last
what you say is as true as it can be
as true as can be uh verbally expressed
but you can also realize that it doesn't
do justice
to the actual reality there are
even the most enlightened
incarnated human being on this planet
right now
i don't subscribe to the
uh belief
that that that
entity that being in its
encountered mind does not hold any
belief
i'm not sure we can sustain a physical
body
when we as far as we can perceive
in these dimensions these dense
densities
don't hold any belief our body is a
belief
to a large extent if we stop believing
that we have a body
then it's gone so um
so i think the and you see
i just said i think because
that's the mind speaking
and as long as you have a body and a
mind you have beliefs
and you express those beliefs by saying
i think
or i believe when when you have reached
a certain
degree of honesty you will not say i
think anymore you will say i believe
because that's the truth of what is
happening when you express something
as the truth they are just expressing a
belief
people who are less aware of
the process of the process
yeah yeah
and directly experience is another way
to talk about it directly experiencing
um i know
it can be used
from the higher self but
usually not
it can be useful it can be used at every
level i know it's a tricky one
i know how it feels to jump into water
this is perfectly right there is nothing
there is no there is no
fifth density or lower belief
in that statement if you have jumped
into water
but if you have read the book hundreds
of books about water and swimming and
jumping into water
all the books that have ever been
written that contain the word
water in it but are not
jumped into a lake or a river or the sea
or whatever
then to say i know
it's just [ __ ] it means nothing
so there you can use
i know whatever if
you are talking of an experience or a
serious experience that you have
taken your body through and your mind
through
but but if you say i know because i
i wrote i read about it i've read it
because i've read books or i've heard
about it or i've been
told about it people use
i know equally
to describe those two sources of
information in one case sensual
multi-dimensional information
derived derived from your
own experience
and the other case second hand
information gathered from
other people and when you are lucky
the other people are we are talking
about their own experience which means
your second-hand
information is more or less
only reasonably distorted
but if on top of it they themselves only
did a
bible bibliographical study on the
subject then it's really
just absolute crap and to use the word
the the verb to know
when describing something you read about
which
the even the author read about or
heard about then really you are very
very
very removed from knowing
but it's still the same word and i guess
at some point we may decide to use
different words for those two
uh sources
let's transform ourselves to joy is a
higher form of love when you
first mention that to me as the calling
oh yeah that was the subject
and and how well it's cool when you
mention that to me as you're calling
it it clicked for something a little bit
later when i messaged you it clicked
that
very subtly joy in a sense is
freer than love and then you sent me
this really detailed response
as to why you feel joy is a higher form
of love so
will you unpack that for us it's such a
nuance beautiful thing
yeah now this is you see you see how
the verbal communication is tricky
in your mouth that's that was off
because it's not your experience you've
heard it from me and
and you you could feel uh
rightfully rightfully so that
my expression of it came from my direct
experience
and because we built this rapport
you your your trust is such
that you took it for truth but it's
not your experience yet
and that's why you just
read it or recited it and it was off
there was no joy in it
and that's always the danger
you know people debating about the
usefulness
of humor and like that's serious
people
giving a
[Laughter]
lecture on joy and
and they are so afraid to get it
wrong or or they are so
they feel so responsible in your case
you feel so
responsible for being true to
truth for being truth
for being true to the message of truth
that that that very
desire is
uh yeah it's a
tight skin you know it's like if you
were wearing
trousers of nikolas cage in
that movie i can't remember maybe
and and it's not your fault
so yeah shared it but let's go into the
subject for the benefit of anybody
interested in it because
after all since it's the subject of this
call
if we don't address it that would be
like fraud right
so let's not give any
let's give let's give it to them let's
give it to them
so no i don't believe
that joy is a higher form of love
my experience
i've been
observing vincent
desperately searching for love
even the world desperately does not give
justice
to the state of deep
misery of this
[Music]
bulk of neediness
unworthiness
weakness
sadness
that baby crying for tenderness
that bulk of belief
that that tenderness can only come from
one person in the first stage the mother
and it was either denied or not fully
given
and then at a later stage
looking for love in the eyes of
pretty girls teens in his age
and it was also most of the time denied
and that needed frustration but it's not
really frustration
you see so anyway i've been watching him
go through all this
i've guided him constantly towards
the true nature of love but that
bulk of belief and desires obsession and
fear and need
was not open to to hearing it right
so i took him to different places slowly
at his rhythm until
at the age of 44 i took him
to celebrate his birthday with a bunch
of
friends in the south south of france
with vieira
and i allowed him to have
all the surroundings that he thought was
necessary for
a great party time and for
non-stop for five days
he parted and danced five to eight hours
a day
dancing partying and
celebrating and golfing and eating
and drinking fruit juice
or sometimes a bit of alcohol but i
never let him get drunk
but after five days
after five days of less than three hours
sleep
per 24 hours and all his friends
rotating taking shifts to party with him
and falling off after eight to 15 hours
each day
at one time at breakfast while they were
sitting
and sipping coffee in a very
tired way and vincent was standing and
semi dancing in front of them and
telling jokes
and they said come on vincent what the
what the hell are you taking you're on
drugs
and i gave
i made vincent reply
simply no
it is joy and i gave him the full
multi-dimensional truth about the nature
of the various frequencies of the only
thing that exists in the universe
but he only got he only got a smaller
version of it
which was that joy my friend
ananda joy is
an unexhaustible
supply of love and
energy and in fact by now
he he realizes and that's why the name
of vincent is not fully
apt even for him because
even his intellectual understanding of
the truth
is high enough but
it is too removed from the history
of the body mind that was born into this
world and then
freshness can you feel the cool breeze
vincent's body
which would be more aptly called vyan's
body or lavi's body
is evaporating from sweat that
was gathered outside under the sun
into the air-conditioned
abode and that evaporation is cooling
that body in a very gentle
and refreshing and invigorating way and
he wants to share that so
i allowed him to do this
julia perfectly married you know people
think they have to kill the ego
it's a misunderstanding you don't have
to kill the ego you don't have to
you don't have to kill the mind you just
have to learn how to
switch it on and off or even to dim it
you can
it's it's more even like to dim it
or or increase it because you can't
truly switch it totally off
even though you can put it at a very
very low burn
and you can increase it to a higher burn
when you want when you need laser focus
because also this is another
misconception of many spiritual people i
would like to quickly
correct through vyan here now
[Applause]
most of you beautifully
beautifully motivated burning desire
suffering entities are seeking
soothing in meditation in the wrong way
you are either focusing on your breath
or on a point an imaginary point
in your forehead or things like that
it's a it's called focus that is
a mind process please
it only has the benefit
if there was 200
construction workers working around you
while you tried to meditate
and you managed to switch all of them
off
except the jackhammer it's an
improvement
yes you are slightly closer to eye
and you have slightly more ability to
hear my whispering into your
eye
here however
it's it's still not efficient
i i can see you can't hear
and you cannot see except with my
eye so we have to rely on hearing
and yes silence is the best way of
hearing
i but you
are not hearing you are not listening
properly don't focus
on your breath don't focus on your third
eye
there's no third eye i am the only eye
so focus not
de-focus widen
your consciousness widen your acceptance
don't
only accept your breath don't act only
accept your
eyes not only accept your vision of the
universe
accept all that is
defocus defocus include everything the
jackhammer
the the crane the gravel falling down
the bird singing the air breathing
your neck the anything going on
all and everything simultaneously
that requires de-focus not focus defocus
like when you watch when you look at
something you will
turn your crystalline
to to focus your vision
at a certain distance so that it is neat
right
but then everything else is blurred
but there is a way of of relaxing your
eye
so that everything is blurred
you have that experience
and you will be surprised how clearly
you see everything
when you allow it all to be blurred
because
it's illusory anyway so why do you want
to see clearly
something that is not why don't you
allow blurriness and accept
everything d focus
meditation please and then you hear
i
perfect perfect so there's two chords
there
the firs the one you just gave the d
focus to commune yourself
into the infinity and void love that
and then the second one was earlier you
talked about
joy when you had your five days of
straight festival
you talked about joy like an
inexhaustible supply
of love energy and that also really
resonated
i like that a lot another core aspect to
joy for me via direct experience
is that joy feels a lot
like the illumination of the sun itself
it feels a lot like you describe this
inexhaustibility
that then in a sense also triggers the
love and again right now we're just
using words
language to talk about joy and love when
ultimately they are love light awareness
it is all that leela let me interrupt
you
let me interrupt you to give credit to
your perfect vision
of the sun the sun does not focus its
light on any object
[Music]
all right it just sends it
in every direction constantly without
any discrimination
and then perfectly everything
is enlightened at the right time and
plunged into darkness at the right time
as a refreshing bath
because if you are constantly in the sun
you'll get sunburned my friend
so i love it this is
a good image another but since
uh you and probably
some other members of this family
like techniques if you want the
technique
try this observe
your retina
look into your retina
i love that it's a good one all right
that's a technique if you want one it's
not necessary like any technique
is just somebody's trick
to reach the same part of the focus
all right here your idram
it's possible by the way both are
possible
i can't vincent and young
but by the way vincent didn't succeed
but beyond did
if you want to play that game
you can actually see already now
when you defocus enough in the evening
before to fall asleep
you defocus in uh
presence and you
you look at darkness and you know you
adjust your focus
back and forth and then you relax it
there will be a point
when you actually see a grid you
actually see a perfectly
aligned grid
that's your retina which in fact well
it's it's a single
it's a single veil which is both
your retina your eardrum your skin
your the inside of your stomach and
digestive
system the yours
your smelling bud and your
dopamine receptors all in ones in fact
all
all of the interfaces
of your body mind construct with
what you perceive as reality which is in
fact
just your own inside the whole skin of
that including the retina and eardrum
is what some people call the matrix
or some people call the veil
and it can be seen it can be actually
seen but not with the intention of
seeing it it's just in the relaxation of
the focus
and uh for those who thought that
there is one big revelation because
that's another big fallacy of
many of the members of this family
that one day one day
i'll have the fireworks one day one
moment i will have the absolute
revelation
of the matrix and the true nature of
reality and it will be a firework
and i will be totally changed and from
that moment on
i'll be an ascended master with a
completely totally different
view of everything i will see colors and
people i will
read their minds and stuff like that
it's totally false but it happens in one
instant it's totally false
that it is so even though
it happens in very
momentous moments
that you will remember for
your whole incarnated time
and even though you your perception
of what you think you would see with
your eyes or here with your ears
the perception of it
intuitively will be very strong
and accurate and true when you are
de-focused when you are absent when you
are not there
and when the other
incarnation of i
is open to it and that
i monitor
closely and i do not allow
understanding and vision
to those who still have a desire for it
because that desire my friend you didn't
look
close enough where it comes from
it comes from fear and neediness or
desire of power
which itself is rooted in fear
and misunderstanding of the true nature
of love
yet also the desire to know oneself can
be just the desire of
intelligent infinity to commune with its
true nature to watch
gateless gate yeah that's the one but
the only desire
i sanctify is to know yourself
which is the delphic maxim that was
written on the top of the temple of
apollo at delphi
2 500 years ago two words know thyself
that's it that's the only one it's the
only desire
worth in town yeah and i will refer you
to an even pure
one of my most beloved incarnations
into
that beautiful amazing kid
i took swimming
my dance
with him was epic i refer you to osho
what you refer to now as also
that's not how
i watched him refer to himself
throughout his life he
also shed so many snake skins my friends
so i will quote one of
the sentences i wanted him to
his
soul specifically
who i am
who am i is the only
question worth asking
who am i it's the
only rebellious act
the one and only
and the first and the last
rebellious act it's the only true
rebellious act
to rebel against your false identity
and if you do it honestly
it's your last because you are no more
once you have really
dived into that question
and dived start with die
and ends in v
larvae
so the beginning is death
and the outcome is la vie
life is what happens when you are not
there
any longer as
that spiny small
susceptible sick
sense of identity
life is what happens
when you are not there
vyan loves that by the way
and it's
one of the things i like to make
all of you say from time to time the
problem is
you misinterpret it with your
senses your
subjugated sense of
i
your hypnotist
yourself hypnosis state
i loved your point i agree with you so
much
the only question worthwhile asking what
is
i ask yourself that question investigate
deeply enough
you'll come to the answer that you are
the absolute
and that's the end of the game and then
you just flower
effortlessly as god's love light
perfectly
it is so but
it's not your experience
yet
so dive into it watch your retina
listen to your eardrum touch your skin
smell the hair of your nose
taste your tongue
i am here now as
[Laughter]
i like to stay without
being but
by the way at last don't feel bad about
it
you have a mission you
are the mission and you are
accomplishing it
i will reveal myself to you
at the right time
i love this game it's so funny
i love you so much it's perfect yeah
i'm totally surrendered i love it
you're surrendered too young but that's
not the right surrender
surrender to i
inside i am in you just as i am
in jam is not
your savior or your guide or is the
provider of truth
i am and i am providing
truth directly to you so be focused
listen watch
watch watch for your retina
i'll show it to you
not viabian directly you and i
alone
i like that focus on the retina as
the absolute and that being that shared
impersonal eternal observer witnessing
great i
aming i love that
i'll send you again my beloved
osho incarnation
on that subject
i wanna i wanna wrap by asking you a
question
about what your feelings are around this
which
you explained to me in one of the
chats that we had previously where you
basically said
that there is a level of when you
know your true nature that
there is a confidence
a faith a conviction along with that
that
unleashes unlocks itself and you
communicated some of that
through me and i thought that that was
really insightful because nobody
has even voiced that to me yeah
yes i reveal myself in two
ways generally
most of the time by pure
grace what
you will perceive as absolutely
random undeserved unexpected
labels
great
which in fact is actually
based on my perception
of your maturity and ability to handle i
and
other times at times
i reveal myself
to you slightly before full maturity
in precisely the kind of fireworks you
all desire
i even did it somehow
to vyan
just before his uh
christening
in giving him a glimpse of the true
nature
of his uh
infinite multi-dimensional vortex
of light and dark encompassing all of
universe
and of course as expected
he took it
for himself and
it took him another three four years
to sober up
you see the problem is you all want it
you want it you want it and you want to
take it
and you can't take it you can only
receive it
so when you take cylosidine
or any chemical
of course you can only receive it i love
it
you take you take a rocket
you take a a spacex rocket
up your top
and it boosts it boosts you
into the stratosphere
actually to the limit of the
stratosphere
but of course because it's not your own
engine
it's not your own it's not eyes
it's not it's not boosted with joy
and with love it's boosted with with
boosting
powder you know with the
with the gun powder or hydrogen or any
other
fuel so it lasts
what it lasts and then gravity
brings you back gravity is just
negative love that's all love is what
elevates you to the sky and our joy
because joy love like
even hate it's just different frequency
of the same energy and yes
there is the
balancing force of gravity and
seriousness
just like seriousness is the gravity
of joy gravity
is the seriousness of elevation
of the spinning force of the universe
so you are just hanging there in between
tense tense extended
between your ground roots
and your elevated
ideals all right
so just whenever you realize that
the top of your mind is touching the
bottom of your ass
then we'll talk then we'll talk
i love your questions actually talk
i i love your quotes i will reveal
myself to you
over time you can't take it you can only
receive it
those are so good have you seen alex
gray's
net of being it looks like this have you
seen this before
this one over here let me see if i can
it looks like this that name does not
ring at all
the name does not ring a bell but um
next one no can you see this on your
screen though
i um that one
i am talking to you through i am talking
to you through a body mind
complex that has only a limited
amount of memory information and
he cannot pronounce words
or names or refer to information
which i have not exposed him to
so no that does not ring a bell but it
looks pretty
oh yes i love
i love how vg he speaks from the
absolute he speaks from the creator
i have not given him the
information that alex gray needs yet to
be able to visualize the true nature
exactly as it is i i love that
it's so nice how you do that i have i've
been practicing also undergoing a
similar process coming from that
absolute or from that great i
am rather than coming from yeah it's
great
i love that that's a good practice
yes you love that but you don't love
yourself
enough when you love yourself
down to your bottomless pit
of [ __ ] situated at your
root chakra
then you will see
that i have always loved you
but for now you are blocking it
because you are trying to hide to hide
you are trying to hide your [ __ ]
from all of us
you should be more of an [ __ ]
yeah not you know i think you have a
great
potential for assholeness
which you are not exploiting
come on try stop don't be humble
don't be you're great
even vincent can see that
you see you see how obvious it is even
vincent can see your great the only
how diving into your
shame
can stifle the fire
burning in vienna so
yeah burn it burn a billion [ __ ] a
bit
it will do a lot of good
even to your channel
people love a an unapologetic [ __ ]
in this vibration this density right now
can use a an unapologetic
non-judgmental
prick because
there are many bubbles that need to be
pricked
so be the prick be the priest
as a person when you get that advice
it's like hey take your awakening and be
a prick with it it's like the exact
opposite of what's normally said is that
oh you awaken and you become this
equanimous
you're peaceful joyous
all right let's rap let yeah let's rap
let's wrap this that was
i think uh the
the densities are calling for
uh vincent i believe this time
i i am telling you
through myself as another expression in
your house that it is time
for you to end the call with that other
expression of myself
that you've had a great call without
this was really nice thank you so much
and thanks everyone for tuning in i hope
you had a good time we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments
below on the episode let us know how you
feel
and give the video a like if it brought
you value
and share the video with other people
that you feel like
it would be really insightful for and
subscribe if you haven't
and let's all adore
you so much vg was such a blast that was
such a good episode
i will reveal myself to you over time
you can't take it you can only receive
it
i love those those are so good
the defocus meditation was great
that shedding the onion layer
down to nothing
dancing around the black hole
singularity
that we are all right adore you
infinitely thanks everyone for tuning in
we'll see you soon
infinite play
infinite dance
bye-bye
you